good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight america's longest war
ended today after nearly 20 years the
final u.s military aircraft lifted off
from afghanistan general kenneth
mckenzie of the united states marine
corps oversaw this war
here was his announcement
i'm here to announce the completion of
our withdrawal from afghanistan in the
end of the military mission to evacuate
american citizens
third country nationals and vulnerable
afghans
the last c-17 lifted off from hamad
karzai international airport on august
30th this afternoon at 3 29 pm east
coast time and the last manned aircraft
is now clearing the airspace above
afghanistan
so we got everyone out and we're done
it's a poignant moment more than 4 000
americans overall died in afghanistan
over two decades including last week
several enlisted marines who were just
infants when american troops first
arrived in that country
so finally after decades it is done
but is it done
just moments after the clip you just saw
after announcing that we had left
afghanistan for good general mackenzie
conceded that actually
not all of us did leave in fact there
are still americans trapped in
afghanistan the united states military
left them behind watch
we know no american citizens came out on
the last what we call the joint tactical
exfiltration the last five jets to leave
we we maintained the ability to bring
them in up until immediately before
departure but we were not able to bring
any americans out that activity ended
probably about 12 hours before our exit
although we continued the outreach and
would have been prepared to to bring
them on until the very last minute but
none of them made it to the airport and
were able to be and were able to be
accommodated
none of them made it to the airport so
that answers a lot of questions in the
past week you may have wondered about
this large but unknown number of
american citizens you keep reading about
who for whatever reason are still stuck
in afghanistan and you may have asked
yourself who are these people and why
are they still there maybe they don't
want to leave that may be the conclusion
you've come to maybe we don't owe them
anything
it would be nice to believe that very
nice but now we can't believe it because
we just learned from the commander of
american troops in the region that at
least some of these people who are our
countrymen our fellow americans
really are trapped in a nation
controlled by the taliban these
americans tried to flee but it was too
chaotic and too dangerous as general
mckenzie just put it they couldn't get
to the airport in time so the u.s
military just left
tough
call us if you make it to tampa
it's hard to believe that general
mackenzie just admitted this in public
the reporters in the briefing room seem
to think it was just perfectly normal
another pentagon briefing but there's
nothing normal about this not in this
country it is appalling on every level
it is the definition of dishonorable
what's the point of having a military
that doesn't bother to rescue its own
citizens this is a serious question why
do we have an army all those guns and
helicopters and missile systems
isn't the whole point of all of it its
whole purpose is to protect americans
apparently there's another purpose at
least in the view of the man who
oversees the military's central command
those trapped americans are no longer
our problem general mackenzie explained
we're going to let the state department
deal with them
and with that tanned and relaxed from
his extended vacation in the hamptons
garage band enthusiast and part-time
secretary of state tony blinken took the
podium
yes blinking confirmed there are more
than a hundred americans who've been
abandoned in afghanistan and who are
understandably desperate to get out
no we have no actual way to guarantee
their safe passage the military's gone
but no problem
the medieval theocracy that now runs
afghanistan has everything under control
the taliban have given us their word
that american citizens will be fine
and with that tony blinken left the
stage he took no questions nor by the
way did joe biden appear then or at any
other time today to explain what exactly
is happening to these americans or in
afghanistan the president of the united
states appears to be missing again
if you take three steps back you can see
very clearly that we're watching some
kind of pivot point in our history the
most obvious casualty apart from the 13
dead servicemen last week is american
power and prestige both of which in the
span of just days have been profoundly
and permanently diminished
there will be huge consequences of this
moment you'll see them both in the near
term you'll see them through the
generations going forward
but for now it's worth answering a
simple question who is taking
responsibility for this
who's paying for the disaster we're
watching
not so long ago that would have been an
easy question to answer our leaders
would be paying the price
until fairly recently the people in
charge understood that leadership comes
with obligations it's not all privileges
if you're going to make big decisions
you have to be willing to suffer if they
go wrong
in the spring of 1912 edward smith ran
his ship into an iceberg in the north
atlantic as it went down smith did not
blame climate change for the disaster
instead he stood stoically in the
wheelhouse and rode the titanic to the
bottom of the ocean and people applauded
it didn't seem strange it was expected
he was in charge he stayed
until the end
so who's in charge of this and more to
the point who is paying for it
well over time an entire class of
foreign policy experts and political
leaders are responsible they watched for
20 years as afghanistan turned into a
pointless mass in which americans died
and were damaged beyond repair and as
this happened they said nothing in fact
they lied about it repeatedly who are
these people the name liz cheney comes
to mind but there are many many like her
and then there are the people
responsible for what has happened in the
last couple of weeks a pull out that
could not have been more ineptly managed
if you'd intended to screw it up that
would be joe biden and as many
incompetent lieutenants some of whom
seem deranged
so what is their punishment
how many of them have been fired how
many have resigned how many have even
apologized that's the best place to
start always
to our knowledge none
not one
in fact so far as we can tell the only
military leader to suffer so far for
this disaster is a marine corps
lieutenant colonel called stu sheller
a sheller didn't decide to abandon
bagram air base the blood of those 13
servicemen last week are not in his
hands
sheller's crime was posting this video
on social media
if an o5 battalion commander has uh the
simplest live fire incident eo complaint
boom fired but we have a secretary of
defense that testified to congress in
may that the afghan national security
force could withstand the taliban
advance we have chairman of joint chief
who the command is a member of that
who's supposed to advise on military
policy we have a marine
combatant commander
all of these people are supposed to
advise and i'm not saying we've got to
be in the
in afghanistan forever but i am saying
did any of you throw your rank on the
table and say hey it's a bad idea to
evacuate bagram airfield the strategic
air barriers before we evacuate everyone
so this is a disaster that is obvious
the disaster is the result of a series
of bad decisions made by people whose
names we know
have any of those people been punished
explain themselves or apologize that's
the question that stu sheller asked and
for asking it the pentagon relieved him
of his command
on sunday stu sheller announced that he
was resigning from the marine corps he's
got three years until retirement and the
pension that comes with it but he's
leaving
here's why
all i asked for
was accountability of my senior leaders
when there are clear
obvious mistakes that were made
i'm not saying we can take back what has
been done all i asked for was
accountability for people to comment on
what i said
and to say yes mistakes were made
i think them accepting accountability
would do more for service members and
ptsd and struggling with purpose than
any other
transparent piece of paper or message
and i haven't received that
yeah
i mean
thousands of americans died in
afghanistan tens of thousands hundreds
of thousands were permanently damaged by
the time they spent there over 20 years
and the exit diminishes our country
permanently
who did that
and why haven't they apologized it's a
really simple question and for asking it
sheller was relieved of command
instead of taking any form of
responsibility for this disaster that
they caused the bid administration
bewilderingly is doing the opposite they
are bragging in public with a straight
face about what a great job they've done
joe biden's flack already announced that
the white house does not plan to punish
anyone
that means at the pentagon or the intel
agencies for what we're watching now no
one
does he believe he was given bad advice
and will he ask for any resignations of
his generals given the high cost
of american and absent lives
no to both of those questions
so the bite administration's position
has not changed in the face of all the
evidence we're watching on television
they're telling you they did as well as
they possibly could have done joe biden
first said that on august 19th that was
prior to the bombing in kabul but as
recently as today the pentagon's top
spokesman said it again
watch the oily john kirby explain that
there was no possible way to predict
that for example afghanistan's president
ashraf ghani would suddenly abandon the
country to the taliban
our expectation was
that the ghani government would stay in
place nobody could have imagined how
quickly
that government would have literally
just dissipated almost overnight there
was simply no way to predict that
so we could spend the rest of the show
the rest of the week the rest of the
year until new year's day forensically
going through each lie that they're
telling you and batting it down because
these are the flimsiest possible lies
we're not going to do that would give
everyone a headache
but let's just let's just let's take a
close look at this one quote there was
simply no way to predict
that the president of afghanistan was
going to fold and run away
so if you want a sense of how ludicrous
that statement is what a lie it is
consider what our government knew about
ashraf ghani the president of
afghanistan according to the washington
post the pentagon didn't even know that
ghani had fled afghanistan until they
saw it on television they had no idea
quote u.s officials were as surprised as
anyone the americans had expected ghani
would stay for an orderly transition to
an interim authority but he did not
inform most of the government's senior
ranks including his two vice presidents
about his departure nor did gani contact
the u.s government which was left to
piece together the absent leaders
movement from rumor and media reports
so our intel agencies received a
combined 85 billion dollars last year
alone in federal tax dollars for
perspective
that's more money than russia germany
and the uk
spend on their entire annual military
budgets
but for all that money our generals and
our spies were confident that ashraf
ghani would stick around for a quote
orderly transition they say there was no
way to predict otherwise
meanwhile no one not the pentagon not
the ca not the state department could
say where ashraf ghani was they had no
idea so our authorities have no problem
finding say a middle-aged woman who
committed the crime of waving a flag at
the capitol building on january 6 but
they have no idea how to find the
president of afghanistan
now that's not to say we are completely
in the dark what our leaders did notice
is that before kabul fell it was evident
that ghani did not care at all about
doing his job and was not capable of
doing it this is the guy that we
installed effectively whatever they tell
you
as the taliban began seizing key
territories all over the country
provincial capitals all through the
summer
ghani was transfixed not by what was
happening in afghanistan but by a new
government salary payment system that
was slated to roll out soon
according to post account quote even as
a cascade of provincial capitals fell
president ghani appeared distracted
according to one official who spoke to
the post quote ghani would want to talk
about the digitization of the economy it
had nothing to do with the dire threat
end quote
keep in mind
gani no background in any relevant
discipline the guy was a college
professor works at j worked at johns
hopkins
we picked some completely incompetent
tool from american academia rather than
like an actual afghan who could run the
country of course we did
because tony blinken liked him
and people like tony blink white
so the president of afghanistan's flaky
personal behavior reportedly raised some
red flags with u.s officials that would
include
frank mckenzie the head of central
command
the post reports that mckenzie was quote
mystified by ghani's behavior
the question is did anyone in the
pentagon do anything about it well of
course they didn't nothing they just
pretended everything was fine because
they're dumb
as the taliban swept through afghanistan
the state department wasn't reaching out
to ghani to figure out where he was or
what he was doing instead tony blanken
and his deputies were working to get
other countries to sign a statement to
send to the taliban urging them to let
americans out of the country ultimately
that statement was signed by military
powerhouses like haiti papua new guinea
and the democratic republic of congo
that's what the secretary of state
thinks is significant getting papua new
guinea and congo and haiti to sign some
stupid document that means nothing these
are children
but no one's apologizing for they won't
even acknowledge they screwed up they're
not having a moment of self-reflection
about
why were they on the phone with the
government of haiti as american citizens
were trapped in afghanistan run by our
new friends the taliban they're never
going to explain
why they did this why they put the
safety of thousands of american citizens
in the hands of a president who didn't
care enough to stick around
and of course that president ghani isn't
apologizing either he was trained by the
us after he was educated at colombia and
he's taken millions of dollars we've
given him and we fled all while claiming
to be a hero who left his country to
avoid more bloodshed rather than what he
clearly is which is a coward
meanwhile his kids they're americans of
course they've got u.s passports they're
living in million-dollar properties in
washington dc and brooklyn and demanding
that this country accept as many afghan
refugees as possible his son by the way
worked for pete but a judge on the
presidential campaign
that tells you everything so to choose a
president of afghanistan
our brain dead ruling class chose
someone just like them of course they
did
suddenly a lot of what we've seen over
the past 20 years in afghanistan in
particular over the past four months
makes sense the experts in the state
department the cia took trillions of
dollars to install people in afghanistan
who are every bit as clueless as they
are
remember it was in june that u.s
intelligence was predicting that the
ghani government would remain intact for
six months
as recently as this month mark millie
said he had no intelligence suggesting
the taliban would take over afghanistan
quickly
there was nothing
that i or anyone else saw
that indicated a collapse
of this army and this government in 11
days
so they believed that they actually
believed it
because the incompetence around him kept
repeating it like it was true and they
bought it
and that's one of the reasons the
pentagon abandoned bagram air base
which would have been of course a much
easier place to secure than an airport a
commercial airport in the capital city
they didn't think they'd need bagram
they had confidence in ashraf ghani the
guys who was obsessing over afghan's new
version of paypal
that's also why the bite administration
reportedly turned on the taliban's offer
to cede all of kabul to the u.s military
they thought they'd have far more time
than they actually did
on the tactical decision of which is the
right airport to have for an evacuation
of course any responsible president
would give significant weight to the
advice of the commanders on the ground
and their advice was to close bog room
and focus on kabul
oh close boggerman focus on kabul
we did that and now a lot of people are
dead
and a lot are still stuck there and once
again to beat a dead horse
no one has apologized
if you caught one of your kids doing
something wrong you wouldn't rest until
that child apologized contrition is an
essential part
of fixing a problem
it's not just practically important it's
spiritually important admit you were
wrong and they won't because they don't
care what you think
and so so to this moment the only person
who has been punished for these terrible
decisions
one marine corps officer who criticized
those decisions
this can't go on
when leaders refuse to hold themselves
accountable
over time
people revolt that happens
we need to change course immediately and
start acknowledging our mistakes the
people who made them need to start
acknowledging them or else the
consequences will be awful hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else